the Joe Rogan experience you read your
Twitter no me neither
never because she likes exactly well and
and what I read about people very often
who've killed themselves oh yeah you
know in the responses that yeah this is
a big thing how bout this guy losing his
[ __ ] job for the couldn't you just
yeah could you just stop what he got a
job with the Saints you like like he
wasn't a better team yeah but I mean
everybody asked some people who I know
like Barry Weiss who's like brilliant
person and she's like oh my it's like so
depressing might it's like don't read it
oh yes generation cannot stop reading
even when it's going to kill them I
don't understand that well it's it's
very impulsive right you see your name
and you see someone what they say Oh
Barry you're brilliant
oh thank you and then you go a little
further and then there's a bunch of them
liking that nuance and then a bunch of
people piling on and it's you know
realize this first of all they don't
even know you're a real human a lot of
people have never met anyone famous
they have know that they are looking at
and a lot of them are 15 that if I had a
Twitter account when I was 15 how does
it horrible [ __ ] to famous people right
just to get a rise right just gonna
react to see if I can get them to react
it's not even things that they
necessarily mean they don't know you but
unless they meet you they don't even
really know you that people take it to
heart so much that they killed
themselves you know a few of these k-pop
stars have killed themselves really look
that up from from a social media yes I
think so I think that's the main reason
and and there and these are you know pop
stars yeah I can't have Bobby Sherman
right you know 1968 reading his fan mail
Gaius oh this one hates me too if Elvis
had a trip to Twitter account hey man
little [ __ ] you give a [ __ ] for sales
14 yeah come on what the fine a pervert
yeah
well maybe he could have used social
media back then that's it right that's
the balance like you don't want Jerry
Lee Lewis marrying his cousin and
drowning his wives and you also don't
want Elvis
[ __ ] fourteen-year-old maybe be better
I yeah maybe a little bit I was a
balanced auction you wonder what my life
would have been like as a teenager with
this stuff because maybe it would have
made me kill myself but I was painfully
shy couldn't really talk to a girl if I
had been able to text them maybe think I
would need some gel over [ __ ] I exactly
I think I could have done really well
with that I would had a lot of dick
pictures floating around 100% I would
have sent it to everybody
well [ __ ] dumb and young you have no
you have no idea that's gonna last
forever I thought that was a humble brag
about it no no it's a regular day but
just any just any old day I've sent
people other people's dicks but I would
think that the whole idea because young
boys love dick pic they draw it in the
crazy that scene in what was the [ __ ]
movie super bad that's one of my
favorite scenes in a movie ever where
he's just drawing dicks and classic yes
it's [ __ ] hilarious because it's so
true that's so true yeah
look we got real lucky that we are not
held up to the standards that kids are
today because everything they do today
that they put online they're gonna put a
lot of things online it's permanent
forever
I couldn't imagine something that I said
when I was 14 being permanent and that
points me at back to this thing about
this football player and things that
people write on Twitter it's something
Louie CK said to me recently we were
talking about this you said people look
at stuff when it's written down like
it's different but it's just talk
it's talked but it's written like people
say she oh she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
tired of her [ __ ] and then you see her
like oh I'm sorry like but that's talk
right but when you see it written it's
like oh my god did you see what he put
on Twitter to see what he wrote like
you're talking to the whole world now
right and you gotta realize this is
different thing and then people get
screenshot of it you can never take it
back just say that we're gonna keep it
forever we're gonna archive it
look he said it he said she's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you can't there's no just talk
anymore but we're wired for just talk
people are wired for gossip and and
nonsense talk especially when you're
drinking but if you're drinking then you
get on Twitter oh you could you could
say the dumbest [ __ ] ever you could take
your life and people have yeah with
justine sacco that famous yes that was
one of the first ones the one who was
yeah as soon as you got off the flight
it was upside down right yeah she gets
on a plane it's almost comical except
it's comical you know she gets on a
plane and tweets that she said something
is funny and then by the time the plane
lands her life's over
by the way Family Guy did a hysterical
version of that where Brian the dog goes
into the theater he tweets something
going into a theater and it's semi
racist but it's and then by the time he
comes out of the movie his life is just
destroyed by the Twitter mob is
literally a mob outside his house we're
not designed for permanence like that
did you'll be able to just express
yourself loosely it's like if you're
gonna write something in a book and
publish that book and you're gonna
carefully consider every word and then
you put that book out and you okay we've
gone over it we've read it that's a
different thing than [ __ ] this guy
[Applause]